so hello everyone
um thank you for coming to my
presentation today
um my name is Philip Robert so I manage
the tech team within seed guide
biologics today I'll be giving a
presentation looking at the past present
and future of MRI manufacturing
um just before I go into my presentation
I'd just like to start by thanking
Mike Fisher who inviting me to talk to
you all today
so in terms of what I'm trying to cover
so a brief introduction to CPI just
gives some context and stuff work that
we're doing and I'm involved in this
type of work before we then move to
looking at RNA Technologies so what
technology is how it's applied that and
feeds into Army manufacture so what's
been done historically and what's the
current approach to manufacture of RNA
nmps and then looking forward how
manufacturing may change
for future manufacturing
um with the final look at just a few set
of conclusions based on what we've done
so
far as an organization is one which
helps other organizations to develop
proven scale up as well as commercialize
their new products and processes
this is across a range of different
capabilities first thing from bar
technology by Therapeutics formulation
printed Electronics
um and so on
I'm from the biologics business unit
which is where I buy Therapeutics
capabilities and expertise space
and this takes place
within the UK so most of our sites are
based in the northeast of England so
just south of the Scottish board effects
leave between Newcastle and York but we
also have some a small molecule
Invasion Center based in Glasgow
just north of the Border just west of
Edinburgh
in terms of the work that we do so that
supports of other organizations so we
see ourselves as doc find a space
between research Innovation and then
commercialization to helping
organizations with their new products
and processes helping them navigate that
landscape to generate their data they
need to secure on what investment
um as well as turn their
existing processes into one which is
suitable for commercialization in the
concept of biologics to processors which
are ultimately is suitable for GMP
Manufacturing
and just probably go away I guess
um
Concepts the organization so the
business has been open for almost 20
years
um large number is completed now has a
large number of collaboration so we work
with everyone from universities smes
small large biology companies as well as
large Pharma and sometimes the staff
this slides will update now actually so
we have probably close to 600 staff
within the organization
with a turnover and objectives to
indicator kind of a flavor of the type
of size of organization
in terms then oh biologics
which is obviously um more relevant
terms we talk about RNA so this is
Center that I work out and my team in so
this is a relatively new facility so
we'll open in 2015 with work starting
proper kind of tour against 2016 and
2017. we work across BSO one bsl2
organisms primarily twice about a one
standards to our scale for manufacturing
process development
but we do have GMP 30s coming online the
last part this is
just a little bit about later on in the
presentation
um
in terms of generally the kind of work
that we do so we work across everything
from cell free microbial mammalian
expression systems use the production of
everything from antibodies or competent
proteins bowel vectors as well as things
such as Planet DNA and obviously
developments today
um
mRNA
in terms of our capabilities in the
space so we have a kind of a general
process offering for the biologic
molecules but Mr and NLP specifically
with expertise in support of
architecture design on a synthesis
um at scale up to many relevant
manufacturing scale we have done with
expertise and purification so again
small scale High throughput screening
and scale up we have the ability to
support encapsulation so most of the
work today it's been working with a
standard for lipid system
um and we have different calculation
systems but T piece of photos as well as
microfluidic mixers and again with the
ability to scale up to that
most our work uh commercial basis is
pre-clinical Supply currently so
production of materials support talk
studies but with the GMP facility coming
online later on this year we'll have the
ability to support the production of
material for clinical applications
all this work is supported by an online
characterization expertise so we put a
lot of time and effort into this to
develop not only kind of but assays in
terms of identity impurities Etc but
also things such as say structure
characterization which we think is
something which is important for
understanding particularly mRNA and
srnas in processing
uh something I think which helps us
develop optimal processes
so that's interested CPI so now I may
now move on to the um
anything a bit more about technology so
what I when we talk about RNA technology
what is it we're actually talking about
so
there were a number of approved nuclear
Capital therapies on the market
approximately 20 that have been improved
across by FDA or emea
um the majority of these products are
non-viral mediated so we have some
products which are barely listening for
state aav products which
um
have a file Vector um Factor but not by
me it's actually perhaps surprising me
for some are
larger faster food products so of these
products as you can see on the left hand
side and
we have some essentially majority of
these are oligo products so they're
relatively small nucleotides so where
their ants that's all going to do for
titles for interfering rnas these um
products function through modifying
levels of existing pmrna or mature mRNA
and also regular expression of a given
protein
it's worth noting that things such as
example can be delivered through
different nanoparticles living
nanoparticles are not the sole domain of
mRNA
um but as you said you have multiple
uses when we're talking the both sort of
stays thinking about mRNA so mRNA um
the topic in the news due to the um
vaccine so mRNA distinct from some of
these oligonucleotides because of an
mRNA we're introducing a
M on a direct into the body that's then
going to be used to create expression of
a protein with the vaccine products
that's used to finance during a
potential future Therapeutics it will be
will be the production of a
therapeutic protein
and then what we see and one with what
we've seen with the products the dates
so the applications occur with vaccines
but also I think the real potential that
people recognize technology has
um is it had the real a bit it may be
disruptive in this space to mrnas and
basis for treatments of diseases are
very difficult to treat as vaccines for
disease which otherwise proven difficult
to vaccinate against
so this then just shows a
kind of selection in terms of what the
breadth of type products that are being
investigated so
currently there's the happiness well
apparently there are the only approved
products MLA products are covered
vaccines and there's a range of other
code vaccines Beyond those which foods
which companies are looking at taking
through clinical trial
um but particularly Beyond its code
vaccine thing about other types of
vaccines but also Therapeutics so a
range of other products in trial so I
think from metabolic disorders but um to
cancer treatments as well as for
vaccination against the more difficulty
vaccinate infectious diseases
which I guess you've seen on The Vines I
think what's exciting about Mi
technology is it's it's quite a flexible
platform for reasons I've come to in a
moment
um
whether it's worth worth noting at this
point but in terms of the overall
potential of the platform at the moment
the only real realized potential is for
say these covert vaccines
in terms of broad application of mRNA
there's a lot of really exciting
applications that may have but there's
unrealized potential
approved by say FDA emea for
um more widespread application
later
so in terms of Technology itself when we
talk about mRNA what are we talking
about so
and two main approaches used today have
been kind of conventional mRNA whether
that's with or without mod but you could
try to come to at a moment
um as well as self amplifying RNA
platforms so the current approved part
of the market are both mrnas both in one
by nucleotides but actually there's a
lot of interest in self-actifying RNA um
through in a number of different
organizations
irrespective which formatted it
specifically
um everyone every mRNA is going to have
similar type of structures we're going
to have a cap uh five men's which is
required for a function I'm going to
have some translated regions which
effectively they exist in the MRNA
sequence but they're not translated
within the cell to make proteins so
they're therefore
can happen a translation
of Interest which encodes for the
protein or the polypeptide that we're
trying to express which is obviously the
basis of the uh the um maximum
therapeutic mechanism of action and we
have a polyatel which
it's just a string of um adenines which
effectively against required for
expression and
and stability particularly when we think
about self-actifying mRNA
um broadly speaking that's quite similar
to structural we have with these
additional non-structural proteins that
sit Upstream of the gene of interest
um these are derived from the Bible
even and what these do is they basically
replicate and then replicate the entire
sequence so in principle we can inject a
small amount of sub amplifying mRNA into
a cell and it will affect the amplify
itself so we can therefore lead to
either the same or greater level of
expression that we might have from a
more conventional non-amplifying mRNA
um
importantly though so regardless of what
format we're using we need to then
encapsulate that that mRNA into a um
some kind of vexer so we'll talk about
today is living Nana power schools
although there are other approaches to
encapsulation that are being explored
and may well be
um the overall future of the technology
the reason for cancellation I'll come to
in a moment but effectively through this
again there was an mRNA LMP that we then
used for
treatments
so the antennas have been designed so
I've mentioned some of these elements so
we have our cat we have I tried related
regions our Target protein our polyate
tail
um without jumping into lots of detail
over you know absolute statistics of
some of these
um I think overall
irrespective of the products that we are
making whether it's a vaccine or whether
it's a therapeutic effectively what we
are coding with mRNA is a is a
um
polypeptide chain um and that is
um
nickel effect now because there aren't
that many
if um
because the MRN FX is going to consist
of different combinations of effectively
four nucleotides we can create very
different proteins with quite small
modifications in the chemical property
of all mRNA compared to something like a
protein where there's you know over 20
different amino acids those amino acids
have very different very different
properties different charges different
hydrophobicities
um and that means when we create a
protein that's you know a
although it's still composed exactly the
same building blocks so one foot into
another protein there could be a huge
difference in terms of how it it's kind
of chemical properties so how you focus
it have the charge
now that's the big how we purify
um biological fiber carbonate proteins
um but it means it's difficult to maybe
have like a very established platform
process because they've handled very
differently within the MRNA
although the nucleotides vary and
there's different options there are
really you know most cases for
um and actually you'll have quite
similar properties so they all have the
same charge
um they're all the same kind of level
hydrophicity
so broadly speaking one of our mRNA is
quite similar to an mRNA not identical
and there's some distinction I've come
to but broadly speaking they're quite
similar which
I'll come to the relevance without
slightly later
now one one is we do have the new
exciting things with that may in the
future lead to more valuability in
different mrnas is the incorporation of
modifying nucleotides so mRNA can be
synthesized with different nucleosides
Incorporated indeed with the current
vaccines both making use of an M1 method
um this the identification I guess maybe
discover the effects of this being one
of the reasons it's been given in terms
of vaccines or why my technology has
been able to proceed to where it is now
where we have approved products on the
market
um Gene reduces imaginity which is a
real challenge in terms of Mi technology
we also gets high level of protein
expression which
again means you don't have to give as
much which again entice into the
potential imaginity of the product so
for current applications N1 missile is
you know
one of the most people interested in
there's other things that should say
meet upside Society in that people are
interested in
um there's still a bit discussion of the
incorporation of multinucleotides
although I think generally most
companies CC's particularly for the most
kind of standard mrnas that they can
incorporate them given their upsides
but there is still further search to be
done with these but also generally in
terms of nuclear size in the market
there's a huge range of modified forms
that can be purchased the in many of
these is yet to be defined
and in some cases do a search of some of
these
modifying exercise has been done before
some of the advances that have been made
since then so therefore what was known
about them then may not be relevant now
in terms of objects have been made so I
think what we are what we see at the
moment is kind of a reasonably standard
posts that people have tried but I think
in the future we'll like to see an
incorporation of other types of nuclear
sites that we may not even know about
this stage
um that may have a significant impact on
the function of the MRNA but also in
terms of how it actually
processes and handles
don't think related site is
with that change we may have seen need
to change some of the prelimination so
the enzymes that ultimately it creates
the MRNA because some of those because
those enzymes
have more likability to incorporate
different modified forms and therefore
we want to go to more exotic nucleotides
we may need to look at changing
polymerases and the balances again
later supply chain which
which I believe is important in terms of
mRNA production
so in terms of the encapsulation so I
mentioned earlier on that the need for
Mr and srna regardless of the format
they need to be encapsulated that's
because
RNA is fundamentally unstable it's
designed you know or it's it's role
within cells is to be the message
between the DNA and creation of a
protein does not necessarily designed to
hang around for a long period of time
DNA ultimately is the hair form material
of the cell
um so therefore if we want to get
stabilize them on there with the body we
need to encapsulate it but also MMA has
a strong charge and that isn't going to
naturally cross the plasma membrane of
the cells we need to also help it in
getting across membrane squeak and then
releasing the size plasma it can be
translated so these the Vex system needs
to protect it from nucleus is in the
body it needs to an invasive static
filtration so we don't introduce our
therapeutic as immediately filtered out
blood and therefore can't reach its
Target tissue
um it helps with reach Target tissue
internalize it and release it to be
translated
um
so there were a range of different
options kind of available we've
converted different pros and cons
um
and again I think the future would like
to see some I think the cafe technology
is really
important the Constitutional lifted and
how we target our Mr and AOS RNA to our
given Target tissue
in terms of where things are now there's
probably
as a reasonable reasonable standard
approach in terms of using lmps is the
basis for
um mrios rnas although again not
ubiquitous system may change in the
future and typically these are based
around sake of four lipid systems so
different lipids playing different roles
to Ultimate Traders living out of
particles so so I'm not I'm not going to
go into accountable structures but
effectively we have because this is
cholesterol and um the SPC which
required for ultimate required
formations nmp you have stealth lipids
so pegulated lipid which
um
improves the half-life of the noun
particle and we have the ionizable lipid
which is really important because it
enables us to both encapsulate the lipid
in a
fairly effective manner but also to
release the
mrnas for sale once it's
um
the end photos into the cell
so it's a significant
um the other little really important in
terms of again Progressive Miracle
technology because the outdoors will lip
is much more difficult to make
um to make them make the
to encounter the latest offer to release
it in the cell
so having gone through a very
um quick with through
some of the best Technologies then think
about how that then applies and how we
actually manufacture RNA
so for us
um I guess to buy some Concepts from
work that we've done so we within CPI
did some it did sum up in some
self-expression which relates to doing
all seeing some kind of MRI ipt work
um we've evolved so in 2020
um with the development of the srna for
Imperial College London
it's caused by vaccine task force to
take that vaccine to bring it in to do
some optimization of scale up
to ultimately produce a manufacturing
process for an slna LMP product and that
for us to go to it really I guess so the
opportunity to develop a lot of
expertise very quickly which is
subsequently built on as well but again
it's giving us exposure to
have a wide range of different formats
of initially srna but now we do a lot of
work with mRNA as well
so in terms of that because of a
standard manufacturing approach
um because then just shows kind of the
approaching and the stands that you know
operations you will take in terms of
manufacture of mRNA so typically be
starting off with um say well save
yourself a super coil DNA so super core
plasma DNA initially go through a
linearization steps to create a thing a
linear strand that is then used for the
starting material for the image
transcription reaction so the IBT is
where we actually
take our DNA with additional polymerase
polymerase with x-ray a mRNA or an slna
both that reaction we added dnas to
remove the DNA template out so it's
easier to remove and we then go into
purification so some TFS some
chromatography
um different processes and have some
to this some actually don't use current
Topic at all some might have additional
confirmatively step but again it's
always a similar
um process flow to say other types of
biology products but obviously
thinking of real estate much very quite
different
um impurities once we have our purified
mRNA post this second TFS step we then
go to encapsulation where we take our
products we take our lipids we use them
to be combine to encapsulate and we then
do some additional filtration and then
final fill
now
based on the similarity between
different mrnas that I mentioned earlier
earlier on in this presentation
um
the manufacturing flow doesn't
necessarily need to deviate hugely for
different mrnas
um so we actually we may be using a
similarity reactor compositions although
potentially using different modular
nucleotides
um but broadly speaking from a
purification process onwards we know
what because the iot post is defined we
know what I'm Purity profile is and
therefore we'll typically try to remove
the same things regardless of what the
MRNA OSI is that we're working with
um what is important though is it's
still put in the size of products we can
get different say secondary structures
in terms of how the amount of
interaction itself but also the size has
an impact or can of an impact depending
on the process we're following
um and that's definitely take into
account in terms of how we've changed
the process with this particular type of
product that we're running through
I think
what we've seen consistently given the
biochemical nature of the process is
that high quality diversity was
absolutely fundamental in that
a low quality material will give you a
low quality product and it's difficult
to rescue a low quality product if your
purification process is based around
removal of impurities
um
and I'll talk a little bit more about
the importable materials in a moment
in terms of analytics supporting the
process so
has a relatively similar set in terms of
in terms of the parameters we're trying
to understand from say mRNA platforms we
often say the comment post you know math
platform so it's an interesting things
like identity impurities
um concentration
but however the method using these are
distinct so there's a lot of users say
collection of recess or reverse phase
um hblc
but effectively looking at the same time
thing the main distinction Beyond
different types of assay resources
particularly within the impurities where
for conventional cell based prototypes
we have a super effectively of
biomolecules like proteins DNA RNA that
we're trying to say pull up particular
protein out of and when we're measuring
impurities we're measuring a lot of host
cell impurities within the context of a
mRNA process we know what materials we
put in because they have spec sheet that
goes with them and therefore we know it
is we're trying to remove so our
impurity analysis is much more targeted
because we know exactly what it is we've
added in there but what we're trying to
measure and that's quite a big
distinction in terms of
um
not it's not sort of assay that we run
but the type of quality standard we can
expect a lot of these processes
the LMP aspects to our sexual drug
products so although we often talk about
the formulations there but obviously
it's really critical for the actual
function of the product so again
sometimes you're looking to measure here
things particular special encapsulation
efficiencies as well as LMP size and
poor dispersity index essentially how um
homogeneous of the distribution is but
again there's there's still some work to
be done in terms of defining what's
required from a um
so Regulators over
um specification but I think generally
there's a movement towards the agreeing
a fairly status
so
when we think about them manufacturing
after specifics what goes into some of
these processes so I spoke about these
explosive being a biochemical process
and no this is okay but
the process inside the web actually make
the MRNA so this is the ipt the image
transcription we take our DNA templates
a bit linearized we then add a few
enzymes a few um subject of nucleotides
and we basically mix these together we
incubate them at temperature typically
about 37 degrees for a few hours I mean
in that period of time we end up
generating ground lead to scale
quantities of material
um which we expect to say a cell based
process
um
you know even in my code process is
going to take a day or two or so a
mammalian process will take a couple of
weeks so it is exceptionally quick
overall and also is really supported by
having
accessible materials
early on
and again when we talk about impurity
profile and purification because we're
only adding maybe 10 to 15 different
components when it comes to the
purification
we know that's what we've added
effectively and therefore we have a very
defining impurity profile which
therefore gives us the ability to
actually rather than
we write a sailboat process trying to
pull our products out of kind of
basically the soup in this process
actually we know we're trying to move so
actually we can always Target the
impurities removal and keep our product
so it's it's interesting in terms of how
we go about defining processes
um but again but also because the
impurity profile is typically very
similar for different types of mRNA we
don't necessarily need to hugely change
our purification process
um it's more about a live impurrication
process to the specification we're
trying to achieve
um
and again because the MRNA is very
distinct compared to the other um
enzymes or substrates in the reaction so
M I know big it's got a strong charge
the DNA templates Orthopedic but I get
digested within the
um within the reactions ever that's
that's basically gone it's much smaller
so therefore within these kind of
processes let's basically a single tff
CFS steps can remove the majority of
your impurities
um
which is so unusual because typically
tff is more of an aid in many steps
we'll use more later on the process for
the purification step
um but it can be difficult to me with
double Thunder RNA I'm not not dwell on
this um but it is an impurity that comes
out the ivt that is quite Sim at the RN
term as say charge and size which is
more difficult to remove and there are
different ways though of going over
moving it that have been published and
people are thinking about core fading
into their processes
um so in terms of a schematic view then
and so again it's just I guess the
perfect you know operations
um where we have our first TFS step
which actually does a huge amount of the
removal of impurity to have a toffee
step where we're removing
um
um we can use this well to Target
different types of impurities or maybe
to try and enrich high quality mRNA
before we have second TFS that just to
just move further
um
but really to do a buffer exchange of
concentration leadings encapsulation
when we talk about calculation
the typical process is really we take
our mRNA within Nature's phase we take
our lmps within typical National phase
we mix them together
and basically by virtue of the chain
solubility as well as changing pH we
expect the M result in encapsulation of
our mRNA and that's really enabled by
the ionizable lipid which interacts
nucleic acids
um and incorporates into the LMP so this
is really a mixing challenge like
standing else and that's why different
technologies that we see whether it's a
TVs mixer here or a microfluidic mixer
um is trying to give really good mixing
to create a consistent quality product
out of the other end
so when we
think about manufacturing there so I
think I highlighted that there's a very
short
um
process to actually make the MRNA and
that's really enabled like supply chain
so the manufacturing process is
registered straightforward and it can be
done on a small footprint but not to say
there's not a huge amount of work
required to get to the point where you
can actually get made for mRNA because
you're working number of enzymes those
enzymes all come from typical E coli
based fermentation in some cases some
abuse-based process
for their produce they're purified
um so really high quality and that's
what we then take into our lives so
um supply chain is particularly
important with this kind of process the
cell based process we're starting with
cheap or less complexible materials and
we're letting the cell do the work that
create our high value product
um
so an interesting thing that'd be on the
enzymes things on the nucleotides the
cap to be quite specialist the template
DNA is a real challenge because it's
specific to a given product
um
I'm good again after the template DNA is
really important for overall product
quality
it needs to be manufactured a high grade
um and that can be a real challenge in
terms of getting hold of that to the
right grade on a reasonable time frame
to not hold that manufact
Ure
in
fact
um
so because these materials are very
Specialists they're not that easy to
make they have a high cost that high
cost feed density
um MRI LMP
um however importantly where we were
maybe a few years ago actually although
some of these things have already been
manufactured by suppliers Supply shares
really you know has really tried to keep
Pace with advancement technology and
therefore actually it's easy to get hold
of some of the materials the costs have
gone down and that's really important in
terms of
performance technology
um
producing costs which ultimately was a
benefit of improving access these types
of molecules or products to the market
um
does that perhaps complications some of
this is that
um
the spot just moved along and there's
been a lot of advancements made within
the MLA nmp technology generally but as
you might expect
you know a lot of Ip is very valuable
and because it's quite a new field
there were I guess some companies that
started through that was obviously a
huge amount of work actually they've as
consequence hold quite a large number of
patterns that can make it quite
difficult in terms of entering the
market because some of the Technologies
you want to get access to or use that
are currently really required for
functional products are patented
um so therefore the need in some cases
to secure licenses
um
I think that's consideration something's
balance as well as cost of goods
in terms of the I guess the equal
landscape and Direction the landscape So
currently it can be challenging there's
lots there's lots of patterns um and it
doesn't make a difference in the market
but in terms of as more companies want
to gain access to technology that I hope
it will lead to license coming more
available but also give how quick a
technology is
developing
I think we like to see that stuff
patterns may become less less relevant
because actually people we're doing New
pieces of work and actually therefore
what was battered and very valuable
sounds less valuable than it was um
there's something to watch might be
aware of in terms of manufactur
um
so in terms of I guess past and presence
I'm not necessarily stipulated screen
passed and there's a huge amount of
detail I think one of some ways I think
where things are just where things are
now is that broadly speaking what was
done maybe historically a few years ago
still pretty much how we may go about
manufacturing now that has obviously
been a scale for some of those um
approaches but in some cases it was
still using similar types of technology
for example like a reverse space
purification
um which is which would work which is
say dynac and academic Labs but it can't
be scaled up to a point we've finally
working with a patch-based processing is
something which is fit for purpose
um and does make suitable quality mRNA
um I think generally in terms of
wildlassing huge changes in
manufacturing necessarily is that the
technology is really mature very quickly
or come to the market very quickly I
know the need is pandemic to move very
quickly and therefore at the process
before and we know it's effective then
there's no necessarily need to reinvent
the wheel at this stage but you know in
terms of generation two things I would
like to change
um I think what has changed though that
is maybe not something that's
um it's seen directly within
manufacturing the supply chain is really
Advanced it's really
um it's a lot easier to get hold of high
quality materials it actually really
supports the running consistent
processing processes and generating high
quality products
the last limitations around
P but RNA the whole field is developing
really quickly not to say that with
development we won't see new patterns
that have to be taken to account but the
breadth of some of these patterns is
like to be less expansive given that um
there's a better understanding now of
technology and the potential value of it
so then we then start thinking about the
future of RNA technology
um
so I think overall as I mentioned a
moment ago that the scale production of
RNA LMP is really quite a recent
phenomenon
um historically they're both you know
it's being clinical trials needs factors
and Technologies for years but clinical
scale is a much smaller scale than
commercial Supply
um so that's quite new and I guess the
interest in manufacturing is really
developed significantly as a consequence
of I guess generally interesting
technology the field generally though is
still advancing rapidly so there's
potential new RNA formats so that's the
example in corporation nuclear tides but
also say not just a linear ml enable
author I'll know that there's um
to stay new encapsulation Technologies
at the moment the only approved products
are vaccine based and there's obviously
a lot of interest in therapeutic
products but the specification for these
is still not really defined because not
there's not a on the market we can point
to and say well that you know that
defines a good therapeutic product in
terms of where we are now given that
happy moving okay from
my perspective I think
as an organization which works with
different customers and different types
of products they're the needs to ensure
the level of flexibility of
manufacturing to ensure that we can
support the product now but also the
view that
example products that may come to in the
future um
to achieve in order to achieve a high
quality product that is going to be fit
for purpose given that we don't know
exactly we don't know exactly what
Point's going to get in terms of is
there a standard process everyone's
going to end up running or actually is
always going to be a diversity in terms
approaches
on top of that as I've mentioned I guess
supply chain the cost
so there is a hike off the goods yeah
the raw materials are expensive but they
also also quite specialist and they are
difficult to make and that increases
cost of goods it limits the work that
can be done at represents the scale
which does impede process development um
well for some reason we'll deal with
quite hard to get hold of so at the
moment things like plasma DNA
I was always quite hard to get hold of
before because there's use another gene
therapy products but as a main character
get hold of and it can really delay
progression of work so if we can improve
the use of the volatiles we do have
that's obviously beneficial but also
given the rate of movement of Technology
we'd like to see things like new enzymes
come in more nuclear exercise come in
those aren't going to be available in
bulk necessarily if they're very
Innovative or very new so therefore
again the more we get out of existing
well more gap of our home material
inputs the better ultimately
um
as well as obviously reducing the cost
of
um
sometimes I guess flat for manufacturing
so I've highlighted before in terms of
the you know there's a reasoning
consistent manufacturing processes that
can be applied to RNA formats
I think the variability in terms of the
inputable materials the different steps
are probably the same
um the process
process themselves softball is scaled
linearly from Sports large scale
um
and you know the recognized benefits of
MLA is having a
currently what Fleet will need to be a
low Mi dosage requirement for say so if
your application so you're vaccines is
pretty low as well as high yields I mean
we can manufacture and small Footprints
um
it also has you know in case it has a
modular construction Etc we certainly
have a payload for the MRNA or slna and
we have our Vector which will transport
it and depending on what we're trying to
express but also where we're trying to
get it to
um which in principle you know we can
mix and match our payload a little bit
to create our therapeutic of choice so
there's already effectively two or
there's some intrinsic flexibility in
mRNA but is there like a 1 fits or
process
so what we see perhaps is that maybe
there's not an absolutely fixed
um
the platform process that was actually
the same steps exactly the same state
when we're talking steps exactly the
same ipt or we use a one-size-fits all
you know um for us as an organization
working with customers we already see
that isn't necessarily the case so we
instead see this is made more of an mRNA
toolbox
um where we have effectively as you can
see on the top here are different you
know operations so our template
purification announcement
success but within that
there may be different things that we
need to run through so that but we may
have different kind of products so
whether it's got different cap on or
different types of nucleotide it does
the IBT run across a one step or
two-step how are we purifying it
um
eccentric and analytics bully will
mainstream across products but in in
terms of calculation are we
encapsulating the LMP into a polyplex um
so in reality
there
you know the specification of these
digitized processes will vary but also
different situations that there may be
an optimal process in terms of say the
ipt but then due to licensing
restrictions or passive limitations and
all of it has to go down a certain route
and therefore we need to be able to
support that and therefore it can't be a
entirely platform process
um
by birth of that so
really what we see is you know there's
always different types of operations
there's effectively a term
permutations of that that we need to
build we need to understand be able to
take to account
um and I think what's really important
is then be able to understand how to set
a different iot related type of
purification and what that final
specification will be so the process
needs to fit the product as well as the
specification um
and if you understand how these
different things relate to each other
then we should be able to mix and match
different parts of the process towards
me create a product that a customer is
looking for
an important for us we see these process
should be agnostic so
if we understand broadly speaking the
window of operation we have so what kind
of size of mrnas are what we need to
change for a given product within the
context of process that we don't need to
the process is run according to
specification required rather than
necessary rather quantity particular
type to say mRNA that we are running so
again so a toolbox should give us a
principle of relatively flexible
approach in terms of say about the
market now and extend what may come in
the future
um and this is some stuff we've been
exploring through I guess subsequent
work which this is what we're doing with
people project under the UBC to again
look at early manufacture to
characterize it and look at how we can
mix and match different parts of the
process to try to understand support
manufacturing but also the views try and
identify um because CPP is a lot of cqas
from the process
I think in terms of other approaches
improvements within maybe a batch phase
would like to see
um so we didn't say ivt I.T reactions as
a batch process with the limits to terms
of overall change the main change with
an ivt is going to be the informative
input
um I mean at the moment there's a lot of
interest within the purification and the
encapsulation part closer so for
purification
um
for some some things like reverse phase
um based purification use large amounts
of T to nitrile it's not that amenable
to scale up it's um
there might be a limiting step in terms
of how we scale our processes so we're
looking at how we remove that here's our
oligar dtfh purification is currently
the main
production which does does work not so
completely platform of also depends on
the length to make the following detail
and health Hospitality low binding
capacities but it does let you know use
cash mRNA and wash your impurities away
RNA removal
um I mentioned there's a few slides back
um so this is the accuracy that's known
to be important although
the overall important specification
that's important to achieve is still
free to be defined but again there's
particular ways of moving that that may
be distinct
um and that's something we may need to
incorporate into our process to create a
Therapeutics that has a lot of efficacy
that we need
um and beyond all these kind of things
that we left out now there's also you
know all sorts of other types of
purification methods that may come
through but again like expected pros and
cons but you know it's a quickest
question is will we see the market
converging on a basically of a single
purification approach in the same way
that same Maps Plymouth University
protein a is a method of purification
um in encapsulation and events that not
explored so some of this is to avoid
existing patents and that is not that
many systems on the market that are
available uh but also again to make
further improvements to scale
consistency this is particularly looking
at different types of mixing so whether
it's a ring based mix so
many approaches
um and again in both these purification
calculations unlikely we're going to see
a significant change in terms of the
overall process flow but it will change
aspect the process
um the other consideration is beyond the
manual
um I guess on the operation is also just
that supply chain and the input
materials so it's likely that we're
going to see Improvement MRI based
products particularly driven through
um
Precision of all materials the
consequence of how we design
a product and what we incorporate within
that so it doesn't want to buy mucus
side Dimension these are you know very
likely we're going to see it um
increased range of more um
exotic but more unused on YouTube site
Incorporated you haven't typically seen
that require different polymerases and
also incorporate those whilst you're
still getting suitable yields there's
also I'm interested in using different
safe polymerases at different
temperatures example to reduce the
impurity profile out of the IBT
if you'll never like to see other
enzymes for capping for example
synthetic DNA templates in terms of
plasma DNA as well as I think different
lipids particularly for their beauty
applications for longer Half-Life and
more specific targeting of your product
to the tissue of
um where the tissue for the desired
mechanism of action and again with what
are some of these Volvo materials may
change most of these go in at the ivt
step on the captivation step but
actually the workflow is getting
unlikely to change but it will change
the supply chain
how process is organized but actually we
still expect to follow broadly similar
um workflow so I think in terms of
getting to an agile or Flex
manufacturing workplace I think it's
really about understanding student
office that we might need and how those
affect specification with some of the
follow-on changes that may come through
and maybe things that basically
just kind of feed into that without to
make any necessary amount
of
changes
and that's basically kind of a batch
type approach
um and something about how we move from
a batch to perhaps to more intensified
process
um
so
and we recognized M1A the high cost of
goods the raw materials can be difficult
for a whole lot more expensive so in
other areas with by post settings of an
interesting intensification so how we
can generate more from the same
um or from a small footprint so one of
your benefits of MRI based production is
that it's overall less complex based on
all the work's been done for the supply
chain and therefore we know what we're
adding there's not that much going on
from that um
chemistry perspective which therefore
gives us the ability to to understand as
well as control the process so we can
model the actions we can understand
utilization components
um how long we can run them for how we
might be able to improve overall yields
that gives you the ability to then look
at Fair batch production
but also potentially things like
continuous continuous production
um in order to generate more products
from the same set of raw materials or
feed in you know some raw material but
overall generate a much greater quantity
of products
um and most likely done with indeed say
ivt components where we're doing this
reaction
that means that you can be able to need
to be able to keep up with the ivt to
ensure we're maintaining a consistent
quality profile
may look like where you go from a batch
process at the top to then affect their
batch process where you start stage
feeding nucleotides among other things
to then drive up your mRNA yields
um I'm purification wise
I go into detail but effectively we can
there's a selection approaches we can
take we can create a continuous ivt that
we can then purify our
product through different different pros
and cons but again because you know
we're trying to do a movement outside of
the moves Etc and the process isn't
going to evolve over time because
there's no cells in it
um you can model our process and
therefore maybe design a favorite
purification about that
once we have purified mRNA
encapsulation itself is kind of by
Nature continuous in terms of mixing of
lipids and mRNA so that's guess what we
can incorporate the process
I think overall with I think
the Mi nmp manufacturing is amenable to
process intensification
um because the multiplying process has
less variability we might see with say
cell based continuous processing but
what this enables to do is generate more
product from the same set of all
materials
um and potentially manufacturing a
smaller scale
so then if we think about
conclusions that what does that all mean
in practice
um
so I think we talk about process
intensification
um and you know the other benefits
reasonably consistent protesting
products and we don't need to operate a
lot on a huge scale or straight A
commercially relevant amount of products
so it really lends technology to less
centralized production and much more
responsive production so some of the
therapeutic molecules of products that
um
maybe of Interest may not necessarily
have a huge range of um potential
patients out there typically you know
for
historically if I made more conventional
biology that might make it very
difficult to justify making that kind of
products or might make them very
expensive because mRNA can be done at a
very small scale
and the process is more
um
platform based and actually it makes
some of these products much more
feasible
um that we may see more you know
personalized Healthcare effectively at
an appropriate cost enabled by this kind
of technology for CPI we've established
this
um
data sense of Excellence those as well
GMP
capability will be based and again it's
a relatively small footprint for GMP
operation but actually we can generate
multi-million doses per batch from this
kind of scale of operation that's really
only made possible by the them on LMP
technology
um
well I think overall that's in terms of
conclusions so my mRNA has definitely
demonstrated efficacy the faxing
platform and there's still unrealized
potential in terms is used as a
therapeutic
in terms of what's being done today also
still kind of being done is that the
approach to manufacturers scale with the
need so we needed to move quickly we
have moved quickly
um
but it's going to be a must go for
improvement so if we say what we've been
to update the generation one what are
the generation two manufacturing process
look like and the scope Improvement not
just in the product but also the
manufacturing process so the nature of
product by Nature means is a minerals
platform production
um
it's my Purity profile and the main
approach remains batch but there is a
particular I suppose just the last few
slides there's a real potential for
testification to
potentially build a manufacture and even
on an even smaller scale and really
drive down the cost of goods
um in terms of other improvements I
think we're likely some real meaningful
improvements for new technologies
um
so the process of these arguments too
but particular product as well so some
of these therapy the products will need
really high efficacy and will need to
not be doing a jet into an imogenic and
some that will only be enabled through
not just design of the products but also
things that nucleize that incorporated
within them
um what we see now rewards that supply
chain is really important for these kind
of products by their nature
um because we relying on having much
more complex data materials that enable
us to move really quickly
um and then we've got the other benefits
of the Sea of Technology what it does
mean though is the technology advances
and we look towards kind of the next
generation of
product is that supply chain need to
keep up with that and it'll only be
enabled by collaboration with suppliers
to ensure that if we identify new
technologies on your approaches that
there's some ability to actually buy
those materials for the like grade
because if not then that ultimate will
become very limiting for new products to
Market
foreign
so that's I think five percent today so
I hope that was informed in some of the
capturing I guess we're manufacturing
many where manufacturing has come from
and where potentially going
um again let's finish Again by thanking
um thermphish inviting me to speak today
um
and I believe we're moving into a
question and answer session thank you